what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesomeness inside
you explode out into the world so you
can do something crazy special now to
help you on your journey today we're
going to talk about seven ways to have
energy all day so as an entrepreneur you
need a lot of energy right there's a lot
of work that goes into building our
businesses to do all the crazy things
that we need to do to get our companies
up and off the ground to turn it from an
idea into something that's living and
breathing and having a big impact you
need to have the energy to do it and so
today I'm going to share with you my
seven ways on how to have energy all day
to put into your company number one is
you have to enjoy the work I think this
is the biggest thing for a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of people just don't
enjoy the work that they're doing you
may have started with some big mission
in mind you need to start it for the
right reasons and then you're not
getting results or you may have started
with the wrong reasons of mine you know
I'm just trying to make a lot of money
or I'm just starting this business
because it's the hot business of this
year that I need to get into if you are
not enjoying the process if you know how
to enjoin the work this it's hard to
have energy how can you have energy for
something that you don't enjoy like you
can only force yourself to do something
that you don't enjoy for so long before
you quit it's just gonna happen if you
are walking around with the weight of
the world on you dreading the go into
the office because you don't want to
deal with that email you don't want to
deal with that customer you don't want
to make that next product you're not
gonna have positive energy but there's
also been times where you've just been
in the flow and you've loved what you're
doing and the time just you lose track
of it and you forget to go to the
bathroom and you forget to take breaks
and you forget to eat that's when you
love what you're doing and the more that
you're doing work that you love the
energy will come and so for me it's
entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs I'm making this video
today for you guys I've recorded like 60
videos today all day long one washing
break so far you know I have coffee
behind here that I'm drinking quick
quick like lunch break while I'm
reviewing notes like there's no breaks
is go go go but it's fine like I love it
because it fuels me when I'm meeting
entrepreneurs tomorrow I'm going to be
the back wall of meetings hangouts
podcast interviews face to face meetings
it's just gonna be constant and I love
it like by the end of the day I'll be
super drained but going through the
process I love each step and so you need
to love the work that you're doing
chances are for you this is the biggest
thing if you do not enjoy the work
you're not gonna have energy and there's
not really a lot you can do to fix that
apart from doing work that you love we
number two is just taking care of
yourself and this is some basic stuff
and I'm not the expert on these things
but just taking basic care of yourself
you know eating right having enough
water often I'll find if I have lower
energy I take account of how much water
if I had today like I haven't had any
water today taking some water it makes a
big difference one of the things that I
do now is in my phone I have a trigger
in the morning first thing in the
morning I drink a huge thing of water
and then at lunch time around noon I
have another notification that goes off
have some more water because I don't
remember to always drink water and I
find that within five minutes of that
morning water I already have a little
bit more energy so I suggest that you
just try that try first thing in the
morning you wake up you go to the
bathroom you wait yourself whatever you
do it all in the morning
and then big glass of water and you'll
feel a lot more energy
five minutes later because you are
dehydrated and soif already hydrated in
our lives so you know eat healthy work
out drink a lot of water just take care
of yourself if you take care of yourself
you'll have more energy to bring to
everything that you're doing in life
[Music]
way number three is start your day off
right a lot of times people just fall
out of their day right they follow their
bed and they fall into their day and
they just do whatever they normally do
in the morning and you responding to
other people's emergencies as opposed to
having a plan and saying hey here's how
I want a day to look like
go through the exercise of what is an
ideal morning look like for me right it
helps if you have your one word because
then you can design around that so for
me to believe what does a believe
morning look like for me if you start
your day off right
I call it the lightning rod effect like
there's the first thing goes right
you're much more likely to follow
through on the next things but if the
first thing doesn't go right it's easy
to write off the day we've all had those
days where like you're you're sick
you're not feeling well or like you
missed the first thing and you had ten
things that you wanted to do you wanted
to eat healthy and work out and you know
make that phone call and send out that
newsletter and whatever it is that you
want to do and if you miss the first
thing you know you don't do the workout
it's easy to coast on the rest of the
day like okay you know what I missed the
workout so I'm not going to make that
phone call I'm not gonna do that
newsletter I'm not gonna do everything
else and you just let the day expire
that that happens I mean that happens to
me it happens to a lot of people and so
the lightning-rod effect is like that
first thing you do if you do it then
you're much more likely to follow
through and do the next thing and do the
Mexican next thing not just because you
did the first thing but you're the kind
of person who does the first thing
you're the kind of person who follows
through it's like a mental trigger
you've told yourself I follow through
and I follow through one thing so I'm
gonna do it again and again and again
and again and so that first thing that
you do is really really really really
important and so designing what an ideal
morning routine looks like that gives
you energy if you set your day up from
the beginning with success it doesn't
mean like the whole days gonna just be
amazing and every day is gonna be
awesome but you really dramatically
increase the chances and I think most
people don't with intention design a
morning routine that sets them up for
success
[Music]
number four is set up triggers a trigger
is a reminder to check in with yourself
to make sure that you are on the right
track so for me my trigger for my energy
level are my hands every time I look
down in my hands I do an inventory of my
energy level so how's my posture doing I
spent a lot of time in front of the
computer my passion has a tendency of
like sloping forward which actually
makes me a lot smaller and it affects my
energy so I want to make sure I always
have my posture up how's my breathing am
i doing shallow breaths or am i doing
nice deep breaths
and lastly am i committing all my energy
into what I'm doing or am I just
coasting by and that's something I do
not want so I look at my hands every day
and sometimes I look at my hands up to
fifty times a day to do the three quick
checks so if it's a no to my posture to
my breathing or to my energy level I
have to go and fix it whatever it takes
maybe I need to go spring to the
bathroom really quickly and come back at
my desk and keep working or I have to do
some jumping jacks whatever it is to get
my energy up high now for me my hands
work because I look at my hands a lot
all day for you it might not work maybe
you don't look at your hands at all or
you might not even think about it so for
you you might want to set up an alarm
every single hour to do the three quick
checks to make sure your energy level is
high some people use a doorframe every
time you walk through a door frame you
do a quick check take an inventory of
your energy level and if it's a no you
have to go and create that energy for
yourself it doesn't matter what
particular triggers you use what matters
the most is it has to be consistent and
that way you can have energy all day
long
[Music]
number five is be around energetic
people if you are around people who hate
their life who hate their jobs who are
complaining constantly it's really hard
to have energy right they are they're
literally leeches on your energy right
they are infecting you with their
negative Low Energy and you know the
sepal you've experienced these kinds of
people you've work with these kinds of
people people go to their job and like
their shoulders are hunched over and you
know everything is negative and somebody
else's fault and just another crappy day
in the world like if you hang around
those people that's what you're gonna
become and it's just really hard to keep
your energy level high when everyone
around you is just squeezing the energy
out and they hate their lives and so
it's thinking about okay how can I have
more positive people around me whether
it's you know whether you have people on
your team and you already have employees
and you know you want to attract people
who have good energy
whether you're working in a co-working
space where you're having other
entrepreneurs around you whether you're
watching videos of people who are
energetic and inspiring and doing great
things like if watching Steve Jobs makes
you feel energy if watching Eric Thomas
makes you feel energy then then put that
on and have an air Thomas break and make
you come alive again right and so just
really limiting your exposure finding
ways to not be around these negative
energy sapping people so that it allows
you to focus on you having positive
energy all day is really important
[Music]
number six is work to your needs
having the self-awareness to figure out
what it is that brings you energy it's
an ideal work environment for you and
then the good thing as an entrepreneur
is we get to plan around that if you're
an employee you may have some
flexibility but especially as our
entrepreneur we can plan around the
things that give us the most energy so
for me a couple examples I'm an
introvert right so I don't get my energy
from other people and I need to have
time for myself right so I don't need to
be around people all day long in fact if
I was around people all day long giving
me questions all day long then I would
lose energy but if I'm by myself it has
some time to focus and do my thing and
how am i routine then that feeds my
energy and so I've designed my companies
around dealing with that that's how Evan
works in my office it's cold
I keep I keep the thermostat outside my
office at 58 degrees whoo that's where
the thermostat is so inside the office
is another couple degrees colder it's
not cool I work better in cold weather
it's also because I'm standing up it's
also because I'm stepping as I'm working
so I'm generating some heat and so I
just worked better in the cold
it keeps me more alert in the wake and
so when Alex and Lily are the people
come over they often have to wear
sweaters because they're sitting in the
middle of summer beautiful warm day
outside and they have sweaters on in the
office if they want to come in they
don't have to if they don't want to but
if they want to be around me they have
to experience the cold embrace it and
enjoy it as well I've designed it around
my work environment
another one is lighting I need natural
lighting I love natural lighting the
incandescent incandescent bulbs they
flicker the flicker gives me headaches
and when I have a headache it just saps
all energy from me so even when I took
over Toronto then salsa the lights were
all those those long flickering tubes
and the first thing I had to do was
replace the lights I forgot how much it
cost it was a lot but I replaced all the
lights in the studio at my home I have
all natural lights I'd like working in
front of a big window to get get air
coming in from outside get natural
sunlight coming from outside and so
that's me some people are fine with
those flickering bulbs it just drives me
nuts and so understanding what triggers
you to lose energy whether it's the
people like the last point or things in
your environment paying attention to
temperature paying attention to how much
you need to eat or drink or you know the
environment or maybe you need plants
around you maybe you need fragrances or
you need a flower and like whatever it
is you picture your dog or you need your
dog whatever that is that gives you
energy if you know that that's what you
need then just plant it into your your
daily routine in your environment so you
have that around you constantly instead
of trying to do something because it
fits into a norm but saxy energy
[Music]
and number seven is work on important
things and this ties back into number
one of enjoying the work but it's
slightly different because you can enjoy
your work but not have it be really
meaningful or this is really like the
work you're doing mean something the
work that you're doing you feel is
contributing to something I'm making
these videos not because I want to see
myself on camera but because I want you
to be impacted I want this video to make
a change in some of your lives like
you're gonna look at your your day in
your life and your schedule and
hopefully some of you make a change and
if you don't then I failed right and
then it doesn't work out you want to
feel like the work you're doing has
meaning if you feel like the work you're
doing is meaningful will touch people's
lives like that makes a difference then
you're willing to do more you're willing
to work harder you're gonna have more
energy for it if you feel like this is
pointless this is stupid this is a waste
of my time and I you know I hate that
like when I'm standing in line or you're
sitting in traffic or I'm working on
some project like this is not this is
not a good use of my time what happens
your energy level it goes way down and
so as much as possible trying to factor
in you're looking at your schedule and
saying are the projects I'm working on
actually important and if not how do I
get myself out of them as quickly as
possible and then filling it with things
that are meaningful to you and that's
not just work it's also family
activities things you're doing outside
of your business that if you're doing
the things that fill you up then you're
much more likely to have energy
consistently than the things that bring
you down so thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because
Elbert Arius asked me to it's just a
topic you'd like me to cover in a future
seven ways video check out the link in
the description and go and cast your
vote also I'd love to know what do you
think of this video which one of the
seven points really resonated the most
with you is there an eight nine ten that
you want to add to the list share down
the comments below I look forward to
hearing what you have to say I also want
to give a quick Charta to cyrus web
cyrus thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one-word leaving
that great amazon review and picking the
picture holding up the book i really
appreciate the support man and i'm so
glad you enjoyed the book so thank you
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
but what one sweet one is one will this
volume you you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details